so you got a proper table this is one of
our Cypress Hill products there you go
yeah so back to like how fun my life has
gotten last two years as more eyes have
been on me waking up in the morning and
getting a DM from Cypress Hill that's
some [ __ ] I called every single [ __ ]
person with the high school and like
just had the best time how did you get
onto the cut like what was just like how
did you even become aware of the contour
what what happened someone put me on to
you you know and so you know like yo
check this guy out
yeah and and you got it right started
from there and we got same way he got
you in the first 30 seconds or a little
bit longer no no right off the top you
know because you know a lot of the stuff
that that you're trying to instill in
people is inspirational in saying that
you know there's no obstacles you can go
do this if you set your mind to task
boom go get it no excuses and I love
that [ __ ] because that's that's the way
that we've always approached making
music we didn't let anything be an
obstacle we believed in ourselves and
you know we set to task and here we are
27 years later rocking out with Gary you
know what you were writing you know what
you wrote made sense and you know I
finished a questioning book in like two
days
you know and it just made sense
especially being involved social media
wise yeah and knowing how to get your
brand out there if they'd say you know
it's funny to me I always tell people it
makes sense like when I when people
really didn't believe it the people that
it most made sense to were people that
went through the machine and made it
look at you mm-hmm cuz then you knew how
true it was because you knew the
disadvantages of having distribution
have the leverage instead of the
creative right and that's it that's
that's the business
there's serendipity and you being here
as well if just that was the Machine
thank God the right people got eyes on
you thank God you had full conviction
and we're willing to die in your sore
mm but now the same you let's pop that
on Soundcloud on YouTube yeah you know
build all the leverage
that's the get down now a hundred
percent so what else is going on the
entrepreneur land oh well you got a prop
in a table yes and this is actually for
you thank you my guy this is one of our
Cypress Hill products in the cannabis
can this is so crazy to watch cannabis
go truly mainstream it obviously there's
some federal stuff
yes gonna slow it down a little bit but
it feels good because I mean you know it
validates all the ya know it feels great
because I mean you know all the the
sacrifices that we made in talking about
it in the music you know because when we
started it was taboo you know especially
in hip-hop
are you kidding Nancy Reagan just had
her run yeah and seriously
yeah like literally like I'm telling you
right now like you we've talked about
it's like I don't smoke her to me
literally because of Nancy Reagan my mom
completely and utterly bought into that
product that she and then push that [ __ ]
on me hundred yeah you know so we we had
opportunities you know leave the table
because of our politics in our stance on
cannabis and stuff like that so you know
to see it now come to fruition
everything that we thought could happen
and that we believed next 20 years and
here we are and you know I know Jack
Herer is dancing around wherever he's at
in heaven if you believe in that
he's probably dancing around celebrating
smoking one with some arc angels and
whatnot because he's the one that put us
down with a lot of the information that
would be you know from Russia yeah that
we would give out to our fans you know
and you know a lot of other artists
followed suit now you know you had
reggae artists like Bob Marley and Peter
Tosh and and all those guys those
legends yes that were championing the
cause but you know I don't think reggae
hit mainstream the way hip-hop did and I
think that's what that's that was our
power is that we had mainstream success
with our brand of hip hop did actually
had the legalization politics in it
which which blew it
then it caused other artists in hip-hop
to follow us and other artists outside
of hip-hop you know so everybody
watching take it from an old soul who
loves to figure out what the seed is
that create stuff these guys created the
framework of what the mid nineteen late
90 and early 2000 guys and gals talked
about they gave permission to the snoops
of the world period truth end of story
hmm it's just the truth
just facts well you know that you you
you know why you you you extended the
rubber band I Tyler's not in here Tyler
my admin I you know one of the things I
was told he does so much more work in
ten hours then he already thought he
could write and I'm like well then you
love what you do and when you see it and
you do it you can stretch the rubber
band and it gives you permission to fill
that bag right that's what you guys did
for a cannabis of marijuana weed you
stretched it made it a little less
tablet don't forget you guys know this
this is just a history lessons Len Bias
Len Bias 0 when Len Bias dies America
went tight on the ax
oh yeah all the kids watching imagine if
Kevin Durant gets drafted and three days
later dies from cocaine and there's no
internet and everybody in the world is
just paying attention one story yeah
that's what happened
that's what and and he went to Maryland
right in Washington DC
Nancy jumped on that scared the [ __ ] out
of everybody everybody yeah but I
thought if I smoked a cigarette I would
die in a spot yeah I mean that between
that and magic in 91 with AIDS I was
finished I couldn't do anything I was
like church boy I was gonna sex drugs I
was like no no nothing everything was
scary everyone's died I don't die yeah
the process stuff that stuff sounds real
good and that [ __ ] I kind of want it
but [ __ ] it I don't wanna die yeah
that's what that's what 1988 291 was oh
yeah the propaganda machine was rolling
so anything against that was like real
taboo yeah it was it was hardcore it was
definitely hardcore but you know you
still have to push through that to have
people see the benefits and I think that
that's where we were able to do what
what can the the Vayner community me
what would
things that we can help you if I feel
like you've given so much to like my
entertainment escapism and brought so
much value anything we can help with
anything
no enjoy the music man I mean that's
that's the the are our first passion
that we started with was was the music
we just put out elephants on passage
it's a new body of work that's very
trippy dark psychedelic and you know we
want people to see this new brand well
this new form of an old formula if you
will like a upgraded version and I think
they're they're gonna go on a ride with
that aside from that we have our dock
that we're working out and we're you and
me right yeah IndieGoGo campaign on that
let's link up the new album and the
campaign on this video on Facebook
YouTube all that stuff let's do a swipe
up swipe up if you want to get on the
dock swipe it yeah and what's that about
how much are you guys raisin on that
campaign yeah and you know it's
basically to tell our story from A to B
yeah every platform yeah yeah for us
it's just about telling our story a
twosie you know a lot of times the
in-between [ __ ] it helped us form what
we have today that never gets talked
about and and you know like our history
is show structure yeah so you know we
want to give that to our fans and and
you know we want one touring we just got
back from South America Mexico and
Canada this whole month we went out and
you know if we're gonna keep keep going
at it
we got December all the December in
Europe Europe yeah and then next
February March the United States I mean
it's well known you know Cypress Hill
wheat or wheat or we stay on the road
you know we're at the word touring back
we think we to harder than any hip hop
artists out there so yeah we're gonna be
out there with Hollywood Undead in
February and March for that for that
particular run after that you know we're
just sort of looking for the new dates
into the summer and and arrests so you
know it's it's a lot of road work for us
because still you know we still carry
that same mentality got to play in front
of people
you gotta win them over got to do it and
then once he once you do years and
you're the consecutively doing that over
and over again it kind of gets in your
DNA and you have to get out and you have
to go perform and you've got to hear
that Roger
you just said that I literally the other
day said oh [ __ ] I travel so much now
that when I don't I god I'm going
through like a detox like it was weird
yeah too much time it you know is is
crazy at first like for us we do so much
road work how many days at home are you
to say we all we all have Cypress Hill
and everybody has like a site project
right I play a power flow he plays in
profits yeah and he does history with
Rab Matic with Cypress jerky so you know
at any given time we could begin afresh
yeah it could be like like maybe six to
seven months of roadwork and then the
rest you know it just sort of spur at
anything I can answer for you guys
before we bounce here um more like
selfish like not look for content like
anything I can you know oh man now we're
just glad to be here with you men and we
appreciate taking the time to have us up
here
alright I got one question do you
remember where you were at when you
first heard Cypress Hill yeah I do
actually
I uh what is it it's it's I was in I
it's either one of two parties in the
summer I think in between 89 and 90
right I'm trying to think who was it was
a Denise mulaney's eighth grade pool
party and and that's a new start and in
Bethlehem tap wood in Bethlehem Township
New Jersey which is like the sticks and
uh and you know what you know and you
guys know this you guys had such a
different sound and like that like
catches people's attention yeah and yeah
I do and then Robbie turn ik Jesus
Christ one of my best friends I mean he
would [ __ ] I mean we would play
Nintendo baseball like just rag
Nintendo baseball when Genesis was
already out hmm just but we'd still go
back to the old school and we just play
he would just play that [ __ ] didn't
repeat did you have to hide the CD from
your parents no my parents my Russian
mother didn't give a [ __ ] she wasn't in
my business it wasn't like you know what
I mean
my I had like my mom was like should be
a boy man she was like go outs like
she's like don't come back until like
8:00 p.m. and eat dinner she was not in
my [ __ ] yeah yeah real quote she first
of all first of all she [ __ ] put a
macro spell on me and she knew I was a
good boy right second of all I [ __ ]
worked all I was doing I didn't give a
[ __ ] about anything but money that's
right I was [ __ ] working it snowed my
mom wasn't worried that I was in a
basement with a bunch of kids drinking
cuz it was snow I worshipped I was
shoveling she knew exactly where was
ding dong would you give me 20 bucks to
shovel your driveway like I [ __ ] with
[ __ ] working artists it's one thing
that you culturally were at that time
when it mattered to me it matters way
more to me on the ship we DM about the
entrepreneurs the fact that you guys are
iconic and touring seven [ __ ] but
like you're my kind of people
likewise I got one last question and I
read something about this I mean in your
book do you still think Alexa is the way
to go because of the whole I think I
think everybody's gonna be like Alexa
play Cypress Hill this is gonna be a lot
of music and this this this right there
what I just did is a lot of what's gonna
happen Alexa louder because I was going
to get it and then the whole that whole
controversy happened and I wasn't good I
was gonna get it because you said you
know you more than anybody even if
they're watching live your [ __ ] life
through that there it is that's true
right I literally for the last eight
years cuz I knew this was all gonna
happen to me have been living my life on
the record every meeting every
interaction I I just knew what in my
heart I knew this was gonna happen for
me I was like [ __ ] it I'm not gonna give
one person that actually knows me
anything other than I'm a
[ __ ] dude it's gonna live my life